on va revenir sur l'affaire de pardieu
qui enflamme le monde médiatique depuis
la diffusion d'un numéro de de
complément d'enquête où on découvre l'
l'acteur voilà avec les propos que vous
connaissez depuis politique et star du
showbe se déchire à travers des tribunes
de soutien et des cont- triribunes au
sujet de l'acteur on va vous résumer
tout ça avec Pascal De La Tour du Pin à
qui j'ai donné un petit peu de travail
et affida Turner qui a signé la première
pétition celle de soutien à gérarde
pardieu et merci à vous d'avoir été avec
nous regardez petit recécap et Pascal
nous explique tout ça c'est
parti
[Musique]
alors que l'acteur Gérard de pardieu qui
est visé par des plaintes pour viol et
agression sexuelle est au cœur de
l'actualité une cantaine de
personnalités dont Pierre Richard ou
encore Carla Bruny ont décidé de signer
une tribune pour le soutenir en
dénonçant une forme de lychage lorsqu'on
s'emprend ainsi à Gérard pardieu c'est
l'art que l'on attaque par son génie
d'acteur gérarde pardieu participe au
rayonnement artistique de notre pays
mais très vite certains signataires ont
fait machine arrière cette tribune dans
Le Figaro je regarde de l'avoir signé
voilà tout car cette tribune paru dans
le journal Le Figaro a immédiatement
fait polémique et de leur côté de
nombreux autres artistes ont à leur tour
signé des contre tribunes il est du
devoir de chacun de refuser la
banalisation de propos et d'actes tels
que ceux de Gérard Dedieu tribune
pétition soutien retour sur les
dernières infos autour de Gérard depdieu
ça commence franchement vous êtes
trop allez on va accueillir parce
qu'elle veut faire une entrée à vue
voilà a est
avec
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bravo merci c'est bon bonne
[Musique]
année c'est avec
nous
bonjour
Afida ça va ma chérie Afida ça va
attention attention bonne année 2024 je
[Applaudissements]
vous j'ai vu le truc
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
V plus pe
plus peux plus mon peux plus
bravo je pense je pense que c'était du
direct et que tout ceci est fait exprès
en tout cas c'est pas grave je vous
souhaite que vous souhaitez à vousz
beuté on va se retrouver dans un instant
avec Afida et on va se retrouver avec un
témoin clé dans l'affaire de long merci
Afida ça va ma chérie non ça va pas du
tout mais attendez mais qu'est-ce qui se
passe par terre direct la chute est
belle ouais tu t'es pas fait mal ma
chérie avec les élégante Afina tu t'es
pas fait mal cétait
année 2024 c'est la pub ça va non ça va
non est-ce que c'est la pub ou c'est
direct en direct et ben voilà on se
casse la gueule le jour de la nouvelle
année ah ça
mal et merci à FIDA d'être avec nous
bonne année à tous J'ai fait une entrée
fulgurante comme à chaque fois mais
quelqu'un m'a m'a fait un piège c'était
une surprise très mauvaise surprise j'ai
voulu embrasser tout le monde et
soudainement je suis tombée dans les
bras de Kelly Happy New York je vous
souhaite que vous souhaitez amour gloire
et beauté ah non non non waouh non c'est
chic éégant la chaussure la chaussure
c'est chic alors Afina merci d'être là
on va parler on va parler de ce qui
s'est passé pour Gérard pardieu parisque
tu as signé une tribune de soutien à
Gérard pardieu c'était le 25 décembre
c'est ça Pascal de la tour duupin est-ce
que vous pouvez nous rappeler toutes les
péripéties qu'il y a eu sur cesétiition
contre cont pétition contre contre
pétition ouais j'ai ça a mis du temps il
y a une tribune qui a été publiée le 25
décembre dans le Figaro et trois contre
tribunes le 26 au final t'emmerde pas
sur les dates n'effacez pas Gérard
pardieu c'était pour défendre la
présomption d'innocence et l'acharnement
l'acharnement pardon médiatique dont
Gérard de pardieu était victime c'est 56
artistes qui la signne une soixantaine
sauf que le lendemain il y a le monde
qui publie un article et qui appuie sur
une chose qui était l'auteur de cette
tribu
c'est yanisadi qui est un proche de
Sarah knfo qui est l'accompagne de
d'Éric Zemour et qui est un proche aussi
de Julie de pardieu la fille de de
Gérard de pardieux et de là
effectivement part toute une de toute
une polémique où il y a beaucoup
d'artistes qui retirent leur soutien qui
disent oui on était pas au courant
effectivement que de du profil de la
personne qui avait impulsé cette cette
pétition il y a une autre contre contre
contre pétition pardon qui est lancé le
29 décembre et là qui rencontre un
succès fugurant elle a été impulsée par
le collectif de gauche cerveau non
disponible il y a 600 personnes 600
artistes qui la signent au bout de 48 he
il y a 8000 artistes qui signent cette
cette cette contre triribune il y en a
une deuxième c'est-à-dire que les
contre- triribunes se sont enchaînés les
unes après les autres il y a une
deuxième cont- triribune qui est publiée
ensuite l'art n'est pas un totem
d'immunité 1er janvier 2024 il y a plus
de 150 artistes aussi qui réagissent euh
là aussi euh également à la à la tribune
de du 26 décembre du du Figaro 70
articles ça a été publié dans dans
Libération euh ok euh bon alors et tr et
une dernière pétition il y en a trois au
total et une autre pétition qui a été
montée mais contre la prise de position
de d'Emmanuel Macron qui a des fois g
rare de pard alors donc la première
pétition qu'elle a signé cinquantaine de
personnalités il y avait Patrice lecte
que j'adore d'ailleurs Carla Bruni
Carole bouqu fan Ardan Yvan hatal
Charlotte ramping Gérard d'on Nathalie
baay entre autres Ariel dombal et affida
Turner Afida euh tu connais tu tu as
déjà rencontré Gérard de pardux moi euh
tout simplement je voulais simplement
dire que Gérard de Part Dieu moi j'ai
grandi avec Gérard c'est vrai que pour
des gens comme moi qui viennent d'un
milieu social c'est un exemple c'est un
un monsieur qui vient de châurou c'est
pas un enfant de la balle mais pourtant
c'est de la balle et on a tous grandi
avec Gérard de pardieu que ce soit les
valceuses au sirano c'est un exemple
pour nous pour tout ce qui est art
dramatique et cinéma donc quand on m'a
appelé pour me dire euh tu tu penses
quoi de on efface Gérard pardieu et on
supprime ces films moi je me suis
prononcé en tant que fan en tant que
artiste et je trouvais ça un peu injuste
d'un mec qui a donné plus de 60 ans à
l'art dramatique l'art du sechemar qu'on
efface quelqu'un qu'on lui envoie qu'on
lui enlève la Légion d'Honneur parce que
il y a effectivement ce reportage qui
est fait et très mal fait complètement
d'enquête c'est pas complètement
d'enquête c'est complètement de de coupe
de tête parce que c'est ces images sont
faites en sorte pour porter préjudice
sinon on passerait pas des images ainsi
il y a pas complment d'enquêtea il y a
aussi quand même des plaintes aussi
pourou attendez vous nêtes pas procureur
ni tribunal laissons faire la justice on
peut pas moi je moi ce qui m'embête
énormément c'est ce lychage médiatique
Gérard est un citoyen comme vous comme
moi il a payé son d dans l'art il paye
ses impôts qu'on laisse la justice faire
par rapport à ses accusations vous voyez
ce que je veux dire
moi quelqu Gérard général qui n'a pas
grandi avec Gérard de par Dieu hein les
Vals c'est un c'est c'est c'est
attendsends parce attends attends
j'aimerais qu'on parle auss avec les
chroniqueurs de pass géradine avec les
rétropédalages qu'il y a eu donc il a
Ivan atalin qui a dit qu'il avait
regrettéatte
aussiard Jacques Weber
Jaber Nadine trintigon Pierre Richard
euh voilà il y a et la plupart en fait
sont venus sur et vous à FIDA vous avez
pas fait de rétropédalage en revanche
vous je ne change jamais mon fusil
d'épaule au jour d'aujourd'hui les gens
n'ont plus de dignité et n'ont plus de
couill vous voyez ce que je veux dire tu
es comm ça parce que tous les gens
pensent à leur biftech moi je défends
c'est un citoyen laissons faire la
justice pourquoi un tel lynchage c'est
un coupage de tête on le crucifie avant
que la justice a fait son devoir vous
voyez ce que je veux dire je n'aime pas
la justice parce que moi-même victime m'
terminé la sentence moi-même j'ai été
victime d'injustice la preuve on m'a mis
un un un de carton je suis tombé
sur la tête de Cyr what the fuck Happy
New Years joyeuse fête voilà quand on
parle de Gérard ça perd de voyez Gérard
je suis tombé à vos pieds hein voilà tu
ton ton collier ma chérie qui ah ce
collier est magnifique j'en suis tombée
je suis bouleversé il faut savoir que
j'ai fait 8h d'avion je viens d'arriver
de Miami jure ah ouais vraiment je viens
de Miami à l'instant donc c'est pe-être
pour ça que je n'ai pas
vu ce
ce piège à con par terre en en revant
j'arrive de
Miami je peux et je peux vous dire que
c'est pas tout le monde qui peut arriver
de Miami et d'arriver à 47 balets
coiffer maquiller sur le plateau de C8
personne peut faire ça personne il y en
a deux qui peuvent faire ça et en plus
se casser la gueule en prime time oua
d'accord alors revenons revenons sur
Gérard pardieu oui K et Afida qu'est-ce
que tu penses des gens qui se suffiseent
de ce qu'ils ont vu et entendu ah ben
vous savez moi j'ai fait plus de 75
reportages je suis pas Gérard mais quand
on fait un reportage et qu'on est filmé
du matin au soir quelque fois on se
lâche Gérard a dû peut-être boire du du
margaot du saint-émillon du Saint-Julien
et il ne savait pas qu'il était filmé à
ce moment-là il s'est cru dans un remake
peut-être des valseuses sur la petite
fille sur la petite fille c'est ça qui
les propos qu'il a tenu sont
inadmissibles je ne suis pas l'avocat de
Gérard je ne suis pas procureur mais
effectivement quand on vous filme
pendant un mois en Corée du Sud
é je ne suis
pas dans la géologie dans dans la
géographie dans la Scientologie je ne
suis pas dans la justice je pense que
l'un chez les gens avec ce qui se passe
au jour d'aujourd'hui sur Twitter tout
le monde se fait insulter laissons faire
la justice moi je défends l'acteur
quelqu'un qui a donné sa vie à l'art du
sechemar et il mérite d'être jugé comme
tout citoyen avant qu'il soit accablé
c'est un linchass c'est un coupage de
tête c'est un c'est un assass assassinat
médiatique ok donc laissons faire la
justice moi j'aime Gérard en tant
qu'acteur et et tout ce qu' a pu alors c
attendsends attends attends ça c'était
le gros débat aussi pendant pendant les
les les vacances là de Noël c'était
est-ce qu'on doit dissocier l'artiste de
l'homme et et forcément il y en a
beaucoup c'est tous ceux qui sont venus
sur la pétition et qui ont qui signai
des contre pétition disent ce n'est pas
possible tu peux pas revenir tu peux pas
dire parce que j'ai vu Sophie Marceau
notamment qui dit c'est pas parce que
c'est un un acteur exceptionnel qu'on
doit tout lui passer ou cétait s Mar
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que tu dis toi
Patrick moi moi j'ai une question pour
pour Afida votre argumentaire est très
clair néanmoins beaucoup de gens qui
sont revenus sur la pétition qu'ils ont
signé ont dit j'avais pas vraiment lu
j'ai été piégé je savz pas ce que
c'était est-ce que vous vous aviez tout
lu vous saviez ce que c'était vous êtes
droit dans vos botes vous ne revenez pas
du tout sur ce que vous avez signé alors
c'est-à-dire que moi j'ai reçu un appel
et en fait le motif était on efface
Gérard de par Dieu et on refuse ces
films et moi j'ai trouvé ça tellement
injuste je n'aime pas l'injustice vous
savez c'est quelqu'un qui a donné sa vie
à l'art comprenez-vous ce ce reportage
est a été diffusé dans le but de nuire
pourquoi l'avoir diffusé est-ce qu'on
lui a peut-être pas dit tiens finalement
c'est un documentaire amuse d'AG on
nétait pas là laissons faire la justice
je ne changerai pas mon fusil d'épaule
parce que au jour d'aujourd'hui personne
n' se mouiller on vit dans une nouvelle
génération c'est une drôle d'époque tout
le monde pense à sa gueule ah j'ai dit
ça je me fais lincher non moi je porte
mes couilles et je vais jusqu'au bout il
mérite oui oui oui la preuve je suis
arrivé sur un
plate j'embrasse les bisous de de de
Kelly sont incroyables vous embrassez
Kelly vous retrouvez par terre c'est
quand même incroyable elle a des des
bisous pourf donc voilà voilà pourquoi
voilà I'm scare of you voilà pourquoi
j'ai j'ai dit ok c'était par un appel
téléphonique pour Le Figaro vous savez
que Gérard ouais GG on pourrait imaginer
que c'est le grand frère le père l'oncle
de tout le monde voyezv ce que je
dire ce qu'il a ce qu'il a dit sur la
gamine le cheval ou et cetera ses propos
en tant que féministe sont
inadmissibles ma mère a été assassiné
par mon père j'ai connu certaines violen
je suis une féministe jusqu'à 100% je
montre mon cul parce que montrer mon cul
est un acte de féminisme d'cord donc je
défend la condition féminine par contre
Gérard il a le droit avec ce qu'il a
supporté
vous savez quand vous perdez votre fils
dans des conditions atroces comme
Gérard moi j'ai perdu couliot Rony et
Tina on a le droit de se taper deux
bouteilles de margaot et en disant
écoute je vais me détendre et c'est vrai
qu'après trois quatre bouteilles on sait
plus ce qu'on dit moi j'ai signé des
contrats en disant je vais te produire
un album j'étais bourré le lendemain
j'ai dit mais tu es malade ou quoi
espèce de clochard je ne te signe pas
d'acord on va à Las Vegas pour épouser
un mec on a bu trois quatre bouteilles
ah ben non je me rétracte quand on a bu
tu t'es vu quand quand tu as bu quand on
a bu on dit des choses pour amuser la
galerie des choses moi je pense qu'en
fait les coupables là-dedans ce sont les
gens qui ont diffusé ces images dans le
but de nuire il a encore le droit à
l'image comment ça se fait qu'on passe
des images de Gérard de pardieu sans son
approbation mais dans quel fait de par
Dieu c'est une victime en fait dans
votre histoire c'est une victimees pas
procureur moi non plus laisseons faire
la justice je parlais de l'acteur jamais
par jamais vous parlez des femmes qui
ont été par exemple qui qui ont déposé
plainte par exemple jamais ce soir dans
vot laissons faire la justice parce que
vous nêtes pas pas jugees pas c'est un
citoyen comme vous et moi laissons faire
la justi par opportunisme cette C
opportunisme pas du tout j'ai signé
parce que passé Gérard et lui enlevé sa
statue et refuser les film je trouve que
c'est un signe d'ingratitude pour tout
ce qu'il a donné pour le cinéma non
quand les v passai en boucle ça n'a
choqué personne vous savez j'ai fait
plus 70 reportages je suis pas Gérard
pardieu j'étais Mo vitime de montage col
ensurable des des montages mais j'ai dis
mais pourquoi vous m'avez fait un truc
pare pourquoi vous ne parlez jamais de
ces femmes qui on il s'agit aussi d'une
histoire d'argent ce reportage a été
vendu 120000 € d'où on explique ceci et
pourquoi vous ne parlez jamais des les
mec on a plus le temps là quand même
laist procureur laissons faire la
justice et si Gérard a fait des choses
horribles il sera il sera jugé comme
tout citoyen merci merci Afida merci
d'avoir été avec nous merci ma ch merci
on va passer tout de suite à l'invité du